hi there day 82.
uh eight days to go
so this morning i get up
and i was planning to do a bit of
listing and reading as i like to do and
i get a phone call from my son mark who
runs link
and he says dad
you're behind on your goals
and i said what do you mean
well you haven't
learned enough
links
and you haven't written enough
and of course the way we do things at
link you know there are certain things
that are calculated automatically like
the number of words you read
uh the number of links that you have
created or saved
i was also behind on my listing because
i haven't been recording my listening
well
i know that i've listened
at least an hour or two a day
but it doesn't get recorded because i'm
listening on my mp3 player so that's
easy enough to fix i just go into my
statistics on my profile link
i add another 80 hours and i'm up to my
goals how much i've listened to i don't
know but at least 80 hours in fact
probably closer to
150 hours i don't know about 80 hours so
i'm up there
but
moving links to learn like i constantly
add new links and i read and i listen
but i don't do a lot of going through
the
flash cards
to move the status because the status
one when you first look the word up and
and gradually
it moves up
and of course i haven't written
and i've been hoping to avoid writing so
i tell my son i'm not gonna do that and
he says but you have to
so okay
i got eight days to go
so i'm going to stop my listing and
reading
um the first thing i did is i went to
the vocabulary pages link
and i selected you know
you know to sort my links of which i
have however many
thousands tens of thousands sort them by
important which means by frequency
so i bring up all of the four star words
because we star the words by frequency
based on how frequently the words show
up in our in our library
so these are the most frequent words
most of them are either status 3 or
status 4. status 4 means learned known
status 3 means that i've moved them from
1 to 2 to 3.
so i go through those and i know most of
them so i move them to four so that adds
a lot of learned words and i keep on
doing it with the status with the the
four star words then i went to the three
star words which are a little less
frequent then i went to the two star
words
so i got a lot done that way this
morning then my wife insisted that we go
play golf so i went to play golf
but fortunately her girlfriend arrived
one of her friends
so while they're off chit chatting i've
got my
iphone
and i'm going through my flash cards and
i'm moving more words
these are my daily links that get sent
to me and i'm moving them to learn the
ones that i know
so you know today i've moved all the
words that i not i've moved enough to
meet my goals there's still a lot more
that i could go through that i know that
i've come to know through all my reading
and listening activities
that i could further increase it but
i've at least met my goal so i'm happy
there
writing which i've wanted to avoid i've
decided i'm going to write
so what i did is i went to the exchange
at link
and i went to
this book
because it's difficult to write i'm not
entirely sure how all the little
humble
symbols get together to form a word so
to start with i just went through the
book here
and there are a bunch of of patterned
sentences in the book
uh
covering
different grammatical patterns
and so i'm going to write them
initially and a lot of them have you
probably can't make this out but a lot
of them have both english and korean
so i'm going to steal a page from luca
then i'll look at the korean
and then i'm going to
look at the english and try and recreate
the korean cheating a little bit at
least initially and i'm going to write
these
uh sentences up
and uh send them in now initially if i
if i can see the correct version here i
need to ask for correction on our
exchange at link but after a while i
will actually create my own sentence and
ask them to be corrected
um
i figure i have to get up to three
thousand because i haven't written it at
all i have to get up to three thousand
some
sentences that means like
you know more than thirty sentences a
day
no three thousand words
so i wrote one sentence here
so that came out of my book it's
probably correct
unless i made a mistake
and so i'll
put a bunch of these in and and
hopefully gradually get used to writing
and i'll write some more and
so i was gonna write um 20 or 30
sentences today but then my wife said
we're going to play golf so i went and
then we got while golfing i was going to
come home and do it we got a phone call
from a chinese friend saying we're all
going out to chinese dinner
so that's what i did so i haven't
written any more i got the one sentence
and now it's a quarter to ten and i'm
not going to write anymore
i am my my main goal now the only goal
that i have yet to complete
is the writing goal so for the next
what are we eight days i'm going to be
writing every day that's going to be a
major activity i won't be adding to my
vocabulary i won't be
increasing my familiarity that way i'm
just gonna be writing and i will have a
conversation with clara on tuesday and
hopefully some more
uh before the end of the challenge
so this is it we're down to the wire
with uh eight days to go
we'll see how it all works
uh oh and i wanted one other thing just
having dinner
speaking cantonese
it was interesting
i am better in
everyday banter in cantonese than in say
russian but i can discuss politics in
russian and i have a lot of trouble
discussing politics in cantonese so it
just reminded me that in every language
the level of your skill in different
areas is going to depend on what you do
most often
and that's not a problem because if you
had more opportunity if i had more
opportunity to discuss politics in
cantonese i would get better if i had
more opportunity to have casual
encounters in russian i would get better
not a big deal but it just means that
when we say that we're b2 c1 a2 whatever
it might be in fact it will vary a lot
depending on
on the opportunities that you have had
anyway bye for now